So here's the deal. Researchers recently tried to replicate a hundred experiments in psychology that were published in India. The Center for Open Science recruited colleagues from around the world to try and replicate on one side. And found that most of them could not be reproduced with the same results. In fact, I'm... Welcome to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Today we're going to talk about what is been called a replication crisis in science. The replicators in this recent study fail to get the same findings from the original experiment. From cancer medicine to psychology, researchers are finding that many claims made in scientific studies
事情是这样的。研究人员最近试图在印度复现一百个已发表的心理学实验。开放科学中心招募了世界各地的同事试图在一边进行复现。结果发现，大多数实验无法用相同的结果重现。事实上，我是……欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们要聊聊科学界所谓的复现危机。最近这项研究的复现者未能从最初的实验中得出相同的发现。从癌症医学到心理学，研究人员发现，科学研究中提出的许多主张
fail to hold up when those studies are repeated by an independent group. Later in this episode, we're going to explore one provocative study that looked at stereotypes about Asians, women, and math tests and explain what happened when researchers tried to reproduce the finding. We're going to use this story to explore a deeper question. What does scientists really mean when they talk about the truth? Before we get to that story, I want to give you some context. The crisis has actually been a long time coming. In 2011, for example, Dutch researchers claimed that broken sidewalks encourage racism. They published their findings in one of the most prestigious academic journals Science Magazine. A couple of years later, another article in Science showed that when a gay person shows up at a stranger's door
当这些研究被独立小组重复时，经不起推敲。在本集的后面，我们将探讨一项挑衅性的研究，该研究调查了关于亚裔、女性和数学测试的刻板印象，并解释了当研究人员试图复现该发现时发生了什么。我们将用这个故事来探讨一个更深层次的问题。科学家在谈论真理时到底是什么意思？在我们讲到那个故事之前，我想为您提供一些背景信息。这场危机其实由来已久。例如，在2011年，荷兰研究人员声称，破损的人行道助长种族主义。他们在最负盛名的学术期刊《科学》杂志上发表了他们的发现。几年后，《科学》杂志上的另一篇文章表明，当一个同性恋者出现在陌生人的门口
and speaks openly about what it's like to be gay, this has an extraordinary effect. So was the gay, it was the personal connection between the gay person who they were trying to show, you know, they're in person. People who are against gay marriage change their minds after these emotional encounters. It was the combination of, you know, contact with a minority coupled with a discussion of issues pertinent. The results were written up in the New York Times,
并公开谈论身为同性恋的感受时，会产生非凡的影响。所以，这就是同性恋，是那个同性恋者与他们试图展示的人之间的个人联系，你知道的，他们是真人。反对同性婚姻的人在经历这些情感接触后改变了主意。这是与少数群体接触以及讨论相关问题的结合。这些结果被写进了《纽约时报》、
the Wall Street Journal, the Washington Post. They were featured on public radio programs, such as the clip you're hearing on Science Friday. Scientists. Finally, in 2009, researchers claimed that by lingualism, the ability to speak more than one language is better for your brain. All these claims had serious problems. The Dutch claim was based on fabricated data.
《华尔街日报》、《华盛顿邮报》。它们在公共广播节目中播出，比如你正在听的《科学星期五》节目的片段。科学家们。最后，在2009年，研究人员声称，双语能力，即说一种以上语言的能力，对你的大脑更好。所有这些主张都存在严重的问题。荷兰人的主张是基于伪造的数据。
One author of the gay marriage claim asked for the paper to be withdrawn after concerns were raised about fraud. Both claims were attracted. Might be true? Might not. We don't know, because it turns out the researchers made up the data. The bilingual advantage paper wasn't fabricated, but it was missing important context. The researchers had conducted four experiments. Three failed to show that bilingualism was better for the brain. Only one experiment showed a benefit. It was the only one that was published. Angela De Brown was on the team that worked
在对欺诈行为提出担忧后，同性恋婚姻主张的一位作者要求撤回这篇论文。这两项主张都被撤回了。可能是真的？可能不是。我们不知道，因为事实证明研究人员伪造了数据。双语优势论文并没有被伪造，但它缺少了重要的背景。研究人员进行了四项实验。其中三项未能证明双语能力对大脑更好。只有一项实验显示出了益处。这是唯一发表的实验。安吉拉·德布朗是参与
on the bilingual-adventored study. It is troubling because we like to believe that what we see is actually the truth. But if it's only half of the results we find and we're effect-hiding the other half of the results, then we will never really find out what's going on. But it's only half of the results we find and we're in fact hiding the other half of the results. Then we'll never really find out what's going on. At the University of Virginia, psychologist Brian Nosec decided something had to be done. Brian felt the problem was that too many researchers and too many scientific journals were focusing on publishing new and unusual findings.
双语优势研究团队的一员。这很令人不安，因为我们愿意相信我们看到的就是事实。但如果我们只发现了一半的结果，而实际上隐藏了另一半的结果，那么我们将永远无法真正弄清楚到底发生了什么。但如果我们只发现了一半的结果，而实际上我们隐藏了另一半的结果。那么我们将永远无法真正弄清楚到底发生了什么。在弗吉尼亚大学，心理学家布莱恩·诺塞克决定必须采取行动。布莱恩觉得问题在于，太多的研究人员和太多的科学期刊把焦点放在发表新的、不同寻常的发现上。
To a few was spending time cross-checking earlier work to make sure it was solid. One of the key factors of science is that a claim becomes a credible claim by being reproducible. That someone else can take the same approach, the same protocol, the same procedure, do it again themselves and obtain a similar result. Brian launched an effort to reproduce dozens of studies in psychology. He published a report in 2015. We found that we were able to reproduce the original results in less than half of the cases across five different criteria of evaluating whether a replication was successful or not.
很少有人花时间交叉核对早期的工作以确保其扎实。科学的关键因素之一是通过可复现性，一个主张才能成为一个可信的主张。即其他人可以采用相同的方法、相同的方案、相同的程序，自己再做一次并获得类似的结果。布莱恩发起了一项复现数十项心理学研究的努力。他在2015年发表了一篇报告。我们发现，在评估复现成功与否的五种不同标准中，我们在不到一半的案例中复现了最初的结果。
Over the last year, there have been many debates about what this means. Some critics say it proves that most studies are worthless. At many universities, researchers feel it's their integrity, not just their scientific conclusions that are being called into question. At Harvard University, psychologists Dan Gilbert recently published a paper calling Brian's conclusions into question. So I think we just have to use our heads to figure out which kinds of things we expect to replicate directly, in which kinds of things we would only expect a conceptual replication.
在过去的一年里，关于这意味着什么有许多争论。一些批评者说，这证明了大多数研究毫无价值。在许多大学里，研究人员觉得受到质疑的是他们的诚信，而不仅仅是他们的科学结论。在哈佛大学，心理学家丹·吉尔伯特最近发表了一篇论文，对布莱恩的结论提出了质疑。所以我想我们只需要动脑筋想想，我们期望哪些事情可以直接复现，哪些事情我们只期望进行概念上的复现。
And we need to calm down when we don't see direct replication and ask whether we really should have expected it all. To unpack all of this, let's take a detailed look at one study and what happened when researchers tried to replicate it. I think the story reveals many truths about the ongoing controversy. When they were graduate students at Harvard, Todd Petinsky and his friend Margaret Shee often went to restaurants together. They went for the food, but they also spent a lot of time observing human behavior. We often, after class, would go to the cheesecake factory, and she would order strawberry shortcake. I would typically order a salad, and the number of times that the salad was delivered to
当没有看到直接复现时，我们需要冷静下来，询问我们是否真的应该预料到这一点。为了剖析这一切，让我们详细看看一项研究，以及当研究人员试图复现它时发生了什么。我认为这个故事揭示了关于这场持续争议的许多真相。当他们在哈佛大学读研究生时，托德·佩蒂斯基和他的朋友玛格丽特·希经常一起去餐馆。他们去是为了吃东西，但也花很多时候观察人类行为。我们经常在下课后去芝士蛋糕工厂，她会点草莓酥饼。我通常会点一份沙拉，而沙拉被送到
her, and the strawberry shortcake was delivered to me. She also likes regular coke, and I'm a diabetic, so I drink Diet Coke, and without fail, the Diet Coke would go to her and the regular Coke would go to me. The waiters were stereotyping Todd and Margaret. The guy was probably ordering the less healthy stuff. The woman was ordering salads and diet drinks.
她那里的次数，以及草莓酥饼被送到我这里的次数。她还喜欢普通可乐，而我是个糖尿病患者，所以我喝健怡可乐，毫无疑问，健怡可乐会送到她那里，普通可乐会送到我这里。服务员对托德和玛格丽特产生了刻板印象。这个男的可能点的是不太健康的东西。这个女的点的是沙拉和减肥饮料。
Todd and Margaret knew there was lots of research into the effects of such stereotypes. Now getting a dish you have in order is one thing, but there are more serious consequences. Stereotypes can be hurtful, they can affect performance. But as Todd and Margaret observed the waiters, they realized something was missing in the research. The previous studies had focused on the negative consequences of stereotypes. Could stereotypes also work in a positive fashion? We thought if we really want to understand how stereotypes operate in the world, we can't
托德和玛格丽特知道，有很多关于此类刻板印象影响的研究是一回事，但得到一个你没点的菜是一回事，还有更严重的后果。刻板印象可能具有伤害性，它们会影响表现。但正如托德和玛格丽特观察服务员时所发现的那样，他们意识到研究中缺少了某些东西。先前的研究侧重于刻板印象的负面后果。刻板印象也能以积极的方式发挥作用吗？我们认为，如果我们真的想了解刻板印象在世界上的运作方式，我们不能
simply look at half of it. The young researchers brainstormed how they might study the other half of the equation. The answer came to them as they were, yeah, eating together. We were sitting in Harvard Square over ice cream and we said what we need is a group where the stereotypes go in very different directions. They wanted to study a situation where stereotypes could have both positive and negative effects. And Margotchy happens to be an Asian American and a woman and we were started talking about math identities and we kept going back and forth and back and forth and then literally at the same moment
仅仅看其中的一半。这两位年轻的研究人员集思广益，探讨他们如何研究方程的另一半。答案在他们一边，是的，一边一起吃冰淇淋时浮现了。我们坐在哈佛广场吃冰淇淋时说，我们需要的是一个刻板印象走向截然不同方向的群体。他们想研究刻板印象既有积极影响又有消极影响的情况。而玛戈·希恰好是一位亚裔美国女性，我们开始谈论数学认同，我们来回讨论，然后字面意义上在同一时刻
we said, well why don't we study Asian women and math? The experiment they designed was ingenious and simple. There are negative stereotypes about women doing math and positive stereotypes about Asians and math. So what happens when you give a math test to women who are Asian? We hypothesize that when you make different identity salient, you should expect different stereotypes to be applied. Todd and Margaret figure that if they're reminded Asian women about their gender, they would
我们说，嗯，为什么我们不研究亚裔女性和数学呢？他们设计的实验巧妙而简单。女性学数学存在负面刻板印象，而亚裔学数学存在正面刻板印象。那么，当把数学测试交给亚裔女性时会发生什么？我们假设，当你凸显不同的认同感时，你应该会期望应用不同的刻板印象。托德和玛格丽特认为，如果他们提醒亚裔女性注意她们的性别，她们就会
see the negative stereotype at work. But what would happen if they subtly reminded the volunteers about their Asian identity? The researchers recruited Asian women as volunteers and asked some of them to identify their gender on a form before taking a math test. Earlier research had shown that when you make gender salient in this way, this triggers the negative stereotype about women and math. Todd and Margaret reminded other volunteers, selected at random, about their Asian heritage. They wanted to make these volunteers remember the stereotype about Asians being good at math.
看到负面刻板印象在起作用。但是，如果他们巧妙地提醒志愿者她们的亚裔身份会发生什么呢？研究人员招募了亚裔女性作为志愿者，并要求其中一些人在参加数学测试前在表格上标明她们的性别。先前的研究表明，当你以这种方式凸显性别时，这会触发关于女性和数学的负面刻板印象。托德和玛格丽特随机提醒其他志愿者注意她们的亚裔血统。他们希望让这些志愿者记住关于亚裔擅长数学的刻板印象。
After all the volunteers finished the tests, the researchers analyzed their performance. Todd was working down the hall for Margaret one day when he heard her call out to him. She just shouted, holy cow, it worked. So I just sort of ran down there and we started looking at the output together. The study found that when the volunteers were reminded that they were women, they did worse on the math test. When they were reminded that they were Asian, they did better. Same women, same math test. Negative stereotype, negative result. Positive stereotype, positive result. The study was an instant sensation. Psychologist Brian Nozek.
在所有志愿者完成测试后，研究人员分析了他们的表现。一天，托德正在玛格丽特办公室走廊那头工作，听到她大声叫他。她只是喊道：“天哪，成功了。”所以我赶紧跑过去，我们开始一起查看输出结果。研究发现，当志愿者被提醒她们是女性时，她们在数学测试中的表现较差。当她们被提醒她们是亚裔时，她们表现得更好。同样的女性，同样的数学测试。负面刻板印象，负面结果。正面刻板印象，正面结果。这项研究轰动一时。心理学家布莱恩·诺塞克。
This is one of my favorite effects in psychological science. Something that seems like it shouldn't be flexible, how well we perform in math, is flexible as a function of the identities that we have in mind and stereotypes associated with those identities. Asians being good at math, women being not as good at math. The study quickly became a staple of college textbooks, says psychologist Carolyn Gibson. It is a pretty amazing finding and I heard about that study for the first time as an undergrad. It's been used as an example in social psychology courses for four years, since it was published in 1999, and it's used as a good example for stereotyped threat and stereotyped boost.
这是我最喜欢的心理学科学效应之一。看起来不应该灵活的事情，比如我们在数学方面的表现有多好，其实是灵活的，这取决于我们脑海中的认同感以及与这些认同感相关的刻板印象。亚裔擅长数学，女性不那么擅长数学。心理学家卡罗琳·吉布森说，这项研究迅速成为大学教科书的主打内容。这是一个相当惊人的发现，我作为本科生第一次听到关于这项研究的事。自1999年发表以来，它已被用作社会心理学课程四年的一个例子，并且它被用作刻板印象威胁和刻板印象提升的一个很好的例子。
But from a scientific perspective, there was one big problem. It had never been replicated exactly. Somebody had never followed their steps that they followed and replicated their results, but it's been used to support further studies many times over the past 15 years. Brian Nosek agreed, someone needed to replicate the original study. He was spearhead heading a mammoth effort to reproduce dozens of studies in psychology. Along with a panel of reviewers, he selected this study for replication and asked Carolyn Gibson at
但从科学的角度来看，有一个大问题。它从未被精确复现过。从来没有人按照他们遵循的步骤去复现他们的结果，但在过去的15年里，它被多次用来支持进一步的研究。布莱恩·诺塞克表示赞同，有人需要复现最初的研究。他正在牵头开展一项庞大的工作，以复现数十项心理学研究。他与评审小组一起，挑选了这项研究进行复现，并邀请佐治亚南方大学的卡罗琳·吉布森来进行这项研究。布莱恩希望复现能够密切匹配原始研究的条件。如果你不这样做，你实际上就是在进行两项不同的研究。在启动复现后，他对其在南方的地点产生了二次想法。
Georgia Southern University to conduct it. Brian wanted the replication to closely match the conditions of the original study. If you don't do that, you really are conducting two different studies. After launching the replication, he had second thoughts about its location in the south. And the reviewers thought this looks like a case where the location might matter. Asians in the southern US might be a more distinct minority than Asians in the Northeast or in the West. And so we recruited a second team to do a replication simultaneously at UC Berkeley in the West Coast University, where Asians are much more prominent members of the community.
审稿人认为这看起来像是一个地理位置可能很重要的情况。美国南部的亚裔可能比东北部或西部的亚裔是一个更独特的少数群体。因此，我们招募了第二个团队，在西海岸大学加州大学伯克利分校同时进行复现，在那里的亚裔是社区中更引人注目的成员。
The team in Berkeley was headed by Alice Moon. Alice was a fan of the original paper. When I heard about it, I just thought it was like one of the very cool demonstrations in social psychology, and so that's why I always liked this paper. She followed the protocol of the original Harvard experiment. She recruited Asian women, reminded them of the female side of their identity, or the Asian side of their identity, and then gave them a math test. So what happened? When we compared just as the original paper did, when we compared the participants who were in the Asian identity salient condition, with the participants in the female identities salient condition, we found that there was no difference in their
伯克利的团队由爱丽丝·穆恩领导。爱丽丝是原论文的粉丝。当我听到它时，我只是觉得它是社会心理学中最酷的示范之一，这就是为什么我一直喜欢这篇论文。她遵循了哈佛大学最初实验的方案。她招募了亚裔女性，提醒她们注意自己认同感中的女性一面或亚裔一面，然后给她们做数学测试。那么发生了什么？当我们进行比较，就像原论文所做的那样，当我们把处于亚裔认同凸显条件下的参与者，与处于女性认同凸显条件下的参与者进行比较时，我们发现她们之间没有区别
math performance. The celebrated study failed to be replicated. When Brian Nosek announced the finding about this and dozens of other studies that could not be replicated, it caused an uproar. Newspaper articles called it a crisis. Critics held accusations about fraud and scientific misconduct. In a 6,000-word cover story, the conservative magazine Weekly Standard said that liberals had been making up research into how stereotypes affect women and people of color.
数学表现。这项广受赞誉的研究未能被复现。当布莱恩·诺塞克公布关于这项研究以及其他几十项无法复现的研究的发现时，它引起了轩然大波。报纸文章称之为危机。批评者指责存在欺诈和科学不端行为。保守派杂志《标准周刊》在一篇6000字的封面故事中表示，自由派一直在捏造关于刻板印象如何影响女性和有色人种的研究。
The Berkeley study, however, was not the only replication of Todd Potinsky in Margaret Shee's paper. Remember how Brian had two groups conduct replications? I asked Carolyn Gibson at Georgia Southern University what she found when she ran the experiment on Asian women and math. When primed with Asian identity, Asian females did better on a math test compared to those who had been primed with their female identity and then those primed with their female identity did significantly worse.
然而，伯克利的研究并不是对托德·波廷斯基和玛格丽特·希的论文的唯一复现。还记得布莱恩是如何让两组人进行复现的吗？我问佐治亚南方大学的卡罗琳·吉布森，当她在亚裔女性和数学上运行实验时，她发现了什么。当被植入亚裔身份时，与那些被植入女性身份的人相比，亚裔女性在数学测试中表现得更好，而那些被植入女性身份的人表现明显更差。
Carolyn has no doubt about the meaning of what she found. I believe that it further supports the original finding and that it gives even more robust evidence to this idea, mostly because we followed the same method as the original study and because we collected more participants. And so we have a more powerful study. At Berkeley, Alice is unsure. I do believe that stereotypes in general do have effects on our lives, but in terms of this particular finding
卡罗琳对她发现的含义毫无疑问。我相信这进一步支持了最初的发现，并为这个观点提供了更有力的证据，主要是因为我们遵循了与原研究相同的方法，并且因为我们收集了更多的参与者。因此，我们拥有一个更有力量的研究。在伯克利，爱丽丝不太确定。我确实相信刻板印象总体上对我们的生活有影响，但就这个特定的发现而言
about whether stereotypes can facilitate people's academic performance, I guess it has made me question whether or not that finding is true. Okay, so which is it? Should we trust the results of the Berkeley study and say that Todd Potinsky and Margaret Shease finding was disproved? Should we trust the Georgia study and say the finding was confirmed? What happens when scientific studies disagree with one another? The popular narrative of the replication crisis suggests that scientists are like dueling gladiators. If two scientists come up with different findings, it must mean one of them is wrong, or
关于刻板印象是否能促进人们的学业表现，我想这让我质疑这个发现是否真实。好吧，那么到底是哪个？我们应该相信伯克利研究的结果，并说托德·波廷斯基和玛格丽特·希的发现被推翻了吗？我们应该相信佐治亚的研究，并说这个发现得到了证实吗？当科学研究彼此不一致时会发生什么？复现危机的流行说法表明，科学家就像决斗的角斗士。如果两个科学家得出不同的发现，那一定意味着其中一个是错的，或者
worse, one of them is wrong or worse. One of them must have faked her data. When we come back, we look at why this idea misunderstands how science actually works. Our statistical techniques are probabilistic and not definitive, and so we absolutely need replications. But replications in our current academic climate are also serving the purpose of trying to vet out academic fraud and are serving as a detection technique, and those two are very different missions for replications. Stay with us.
更糟的是，其中一个是错的或更糟的是。其中一个一定伪造了她的数据。当我们回来时，我们将探讨为什么这种观点误解了科学实际运作的方式。我们的统计技术是概率性的，而不是决定性的，所以我们绝对需要复现。但在我们目前的学术气候下，复现也起到了试图查处学术欺诈和作为检测技术的作用，而这两者对复现来说是截然不同的使命。请继续关注。
Support for this podcast and the following message come from the all-new Toyota Prius, thanks to a new double wishbone rear suspension and a lower center of gravity, the 2016 Prius makes any getaway more thrilling, and with modern striking lines and standard by LED headlights, it has an edge at every angle. With sleek styling and a surprisingly exhilarating ride, the 2016 Prius is anything but expected. The all-new 2016 Toyota Prius, it's what's next. Support also comes from Weebly. You don't have to be a web designer or no code to create
对本 podcast 以及以下信息的支持来自全新丰田普锐斯，得益于全新的双叉臂后悬挂和更低的重心，2016款普锐斯让任何逃亡都更加惊险刺激，凭借现代醒目的线条和标准的双LED大灯，它在各个角度都独具优势。凭借流线型的造型和令人惊讶的爽快驾驶体验，2016款普锐斯绝对在意料之外。全新2016款丰田普锐斯，这就是未来。支持还来自 Weebly。您无需成为网页设计师或懂代码，就能使用 Weebly 创建
a fantastic website with Weebly. Created for people with the courage to start their own business and the dream to be their own boss. Choose from professionally designed mobile friendly themes. then just drag and drop to quickly build and publish your site and update your site on any device. Get started for free at weebly.com slash brain. W-E-E-B-L-Y dot com slash brain. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We're taking a look today at how science works and the so-called replication crisis in
一个出色的网站。专为有勇气创办自己企业和梦想成为自己老板的人而设计。从专业设计、移动友好的主题中进行选择。然后只需拖放即可快速构建和发布您的网站，并在任何设备上更新您的网站。在 weebly.com 斜杠 brain 免费开始使用。W-E-E-B-L-Y 点 com 斜杠 brain。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。今天我们来看看科学是如何运作的以及所谓的复现危机
the social sciences. As I listened to the news reports, I found myself drawing an analogy with my own profession, journalism. Here's what I mean. A few years ago, a reporter for the New York Times was caught fabricating stories. Instead of traveling to various locations and interviewing people, he simply made stuff up. The newspaper went back and re-reported the story's Jason Blair had written. When the facts didn't match, the reporter was fired. Imagine for a second what would happen if we re-reported every story by every reporter
社会科学。当我听到新闻报道时，我不禁将之与我自己的职业——新闻业进行类比。我的意思是这样的。几年前，《纽约时报》的一名记者被发现在捏造故事。他没有前往各地并采访人们，而是直接编造东西。这家报纸回过头来重新报道了杰森·布莱尔写的故事。当事实不符时，这位记者被解雇了。想象一下，如果我们将《纽约时报》每位记者的每个故事都重新报道一遍，会发生什么？即使记者们做得非常出色，旧的新闻故事也可能不匹配。消息来源可能不会再次看到完全相同的事情。有时，或者情况发生了变化，消息来源可能会说出完全不同的东西。因此，当两名记者没有产出相同的故事时，可能是其中一人在捏造东西。但更有可能的是，他们俩都是对的。现在，我知道你在想什么。新闻是讲故事，科学关乎数据。但让我们仔细看看卡罗琳·吉布森和爱丽丝·穆恩对托德·佩蒂斯基研究的复现中发生了什么。
at the New York Times. Even when reporters are doing a perfectly good job, the older news stories might not match. A source might not see exactly the same thing again. Sometimes, or the circumstances have changed, a source might say something completely different. So when two reporters don't produce the same story, it could be that one of them is making stuff up. But much more likely, is that both of them are right. Now, I know what you're thinking. Journalism is storytelling, science is about data. But let's look closely at what happened in the replications that Carolyn Gibson and Alice Moon did of Todd Petinsky's study.
在最初的研究中，女性主持了实验。在佐治亚州，引导者也是女性。但在复现失败的伯克利，男性和女性引导者都主持了实验。这会有所不同吗？我们要明确一点，所以这不是一次精确的复现。所以这里有一个例子。论文中清楚地提到，我不知道这个因素是否重要，在一项研究中，实验者的性别是男性，而在另一项研究中，实验者的性别是女性。我不知道这是否是一个可以解释这两项研究之间差异的因素。因此，让我们明确指出，它不是一次精确的复现。
In the original study, women administered the experiment. In Georgia, the facilitator was also female. But in Berkeley, where the replication failed, both male and female facilitators administered the study. Could that have made a difference? Let's be clear, so it was not an exact replication. So here's an example. It mentions clearly in the paper that, and I don't know whether this factor is important or not, that in one study the experimenter gender were males, and another study the experimenter gender were females. I have no idea whether that's a factor that could explain the difference between the two studies. And so let's be clear about what it's not an exact replication.
这是来自宾夕法尼亚大学的埃里克·布拉德洛。他绝对有资格谈论这些事情。在这里的沃顿商学院花了四年时间研究统计学和数学。后来获得了统计学博士学位。在过去的20年里，我一直将统计方法应用于许多问题，但我认为自己是一个数理社会科学家。埃里克认为，要求研究实现统计复现，在得出任何一个是真是假的结论之前要或多或少完美匹配，就像要求两个记者去
This is Eric Bradlow from the University of Pennsylvania. He's eminently qualified to talk about this stuff. Spent four years here at Wharton studying statistics and mathematics. Went on to get my PhD in statistics. And for the last 20 years, I've been applying statistical methods to lots of problems, but I consider myself a mathematical social scientist. Eric believes that requiring studies to achieve statistical replication, to match more or less perfectly, before you conclude that either is true, is like requiring two reporters to
报道一场篮球比赛，回来时带着几乎完全相同的故事一样。精确复现是那种不存在的神话般的象牙塔事物之一。我们真正需要思考的是，如果研究没有复现，为什么没有复现，即使它没有精确复现，它实际上也可能强化最初的发现。换句话说，你可能会更加确定。这不仅适用于心理学研究。埃里克告诉我，美国国立卫生研究院的研究人员曾发现，给实验室老鼠使用镇静剂后，花了35分钟
cover a basketball game and come back with nearly identical stories. Exact replication is one of those mythological ivory tower things that doesn't exist. What we really need to think about is if the study doesn't replicate, why doesn't it replicate, and even if it doesn't replicate exactly, it may actually reinforce the original finding. In other words, you may be more certain. This isn't just true about studies and psychology. Eric told me that NIH researchers once found that lab mice, given a sedative, took 35 minutes
才恢复。当重复实验时，老鼠用了16分钟才恢复。科学家们抓耳挠腮。这毫无道理。他们花了一段时间才弄明白，一个本不该产生影响的因素确实产生了影响。在两次实验之间，动物笼子里的木屑被更换了。事实证明，红雪松和松木屑加快了镇静剂代谢的速度。桦木或枫木则不会。
to recover. When the experiment was repeated, the mice took 16 minutes to recover. The scientists scratched their heads. It made no sense. It took a while to figure out that something that shouldn't have made a difference did. In between the two experiments, wood shavings in the animal cages were changed. Turns out that red cedar and pine shavings step up the speed at which the sedative was metabolized. Birch or maple don't.
这并不是说重复实验是无用或毫无意义的。它极其有价值。但复现主要帮助我们理解围绕某种现象的细微差别。它们作为检测欺诈的工具并没有多大用处。仅仅因为你得到不同的结果并不意味着你不应该信任它们。它们在彼此的误差范围内有多少？是否存在其他变量，使得在大学A进行的实验和在大学B进行的实验不会产生完全相同的结果？我认为这是一种更好的看待方式，而不是说，如果你没有得到完全相同的结果
This is not to say that repeating experiments is useless or pointless. It's incredibly valuable. But replications primarily help us understand the nuances around a phenomenon. They're not very useful as a tool to detect fraud. Just because you get different results doesn't mean you shouldn't trust them. How much are they with an margin of error of each other? Are there other variables that would make it so that study done at University A and the study done at University B wouldn't yield exactly the same thing? I think that's a better way of looking at it than say, if you don't get exactly the same
结果，甚至是几乎相同的果，你就不能相信它们。我认为这是科学的表层水平。我认为你需要深入了解。因此，当你自己看到一项未被复现的研究，或者你看有时被称为失败的复现时，你难道不在脑海深处说，嗯，这推翻了第一项研究，你真的从来没有那样想过吗？“从来”是个漫长的词，“从来说”就是“从来说”就是强烈的词，你知道我在
results or even results that are very nearly the same, you can't trust them. I think that's a superficial level of science. I think you need to go below that. So when you yourself look at a study that has not replicated or you looked at what sometimes called a failed replication do you not at the back of your mind say well this disproves the first study do you actually never think that way never's a long word never says never said never said strong word you know i'm
想，我得想想那部詹姆斯·邦德电影，肖恩·康纳利说我再也不会演詹姆斯·邦德了，然后十五年后他出了一部电影叫《永不说不》。不，不，我绝不会这么说，但我会说以下的话。假设你做了一项研究，你发现，你知道，参加SAT预科课程的人在SAT上的表现好15%。假设其他人做了一项研究，结果只有3%。现在，有两种可能性。
thinking i have to think of that james bond movie when shan connery said i will never do james bond again and then fifteen years later he came out with a movie called Never Say Never Again. No, no, I would never say that, but I would say the following. Let's imagine that you do a study and that you find that, you know, people that take an SAT prep course do 15% better on the SAT. And let's imagine that someone else does a study and the answer is only 3%. Now, there's two possibilities.
一种是第一项研究出于某种原因高估了效应。这完全是有可能的。因此，3%小于15%。但请注意，如果你将这两项研究结合起来，你的发现在某种意义上实际上可能更强，我现在更确信SAT预科有助于在SAT上的表现。现在，效应量可能会从15%缩小到11%，但也请注意，我现在可能已经翻倍
One is the first study for whatever reason overestimated the effect. That's entirely possible. And therefore, 3% is less than 15%. But note, if you combine those two studies together, your finding might actually be stronger in the sense, I'm now more sure that SAT prep helps performance on the SAT. Now, the effect size may shrink from 15% to 11%, but also notice I've possibly now doubled
或三倍了我的样本量，所以我的不确定性下降了，现在我甚至可能更确信SAT预科有帮助，也许不像它在第一项研究中那样有帮助，但我仍然更确信它有帮助，但我仍然更确信它确实有效。然而，当你想到科学的不同分支时，难道没有一些科学分支，当你观察粒子物理学时，你可以非常可预测地预期同一事情一遍又一遍地发生吗？例如，你会期望如果你发射，你知道，20,000个质子从枪里出来，它们基本上会做相同的事情
or tripled my sample size, so my uncertainty goes down, and now I may even be more sure that SAT prep helps, maybe not to the degree that it helped in the first study, but still I'm more sure that it helped in the first study, but still I'm more sure that it's actually effective. When you think about different branches of science, though, aren't there branches of science where you can expect the same thing to happen very predictably over and over again when you look at particle physics, for example, you would expect that if you fire, you know, 20,000 protons out of a gun, that they're basically going to do the same thing pretty
差不多每一次。嗯，这是一个你在测试我记忆力边界的例子，我当年在宾大上粒子物理学课时学到的。但我的理解当然是，这也是统计学家所研究的，对吧？我们研究随机性的概念，所以每一门科学，每一个学科，除非你在讨论一个等号，比如E等于MC平方。E并不约等于MC平方。它实际上等于。大多数物理定律和事物都不是等号。有约号，所以这意味着其中存在随机性。我想如果你发射20,000个质子，你会看到它们与其他粒子碰撞的方式存在偏差
much every time. Well, it's been a you're testing the boundary of my memory of my particle physics class when I took it here at Penn But my understanding is of course, and this is what statisticians study right? We study the concept of randomness and so every science every discipline unless you're talking about an equal sign like E equals MC squared. E doesn't approximately equal MC squared. It actually equals. Most physical laws and things aren't equal signs. There's approximate signs and so that means there's randomness to it. I think if you fired 20,000 protons, you would see that there's a deviation in the way they collide with other particles
而且存在随机性。我认为社会科学中也是如此。你引入500名受试者，你在大学A引入他们，你在大学B引入他们，人们的回答中存在随机性。当然，你希望总体模式是相似的，但这种认为你会得到完全相同发现的信念，我不确定这是科学应该努力追求的。
and there's randomness. I think the same thing is true in the social sciences. You bring in 500 subjects, you bring them in at University A, you bring them in at University B, there's randomness in people's answers. Of course, you would hope the overall patterns would be similar, but the fact that it's this belief that you're gonna get exactly the same findings, I'm not sure that something science should be striving for.
任何单独的研究都只是那样，一项单独的研究。它不是真理。每个观察都是一个点，是一个点，我们观察点，然后我们观察更多的点，如果这些点复现了，那就太好了，然后我们就有更多的信念。科学是关于知识的演进，对吧？但这个过程永无止境。总会有更多的事情要揭示，更多的细微差别。我们对我们所知道的事情变得更加确定，我们也对什么是
Any individual study is just that, an individual study. It isn't the truth. Every observation is a point, it's a dot, and we observe dots, and then we observe more dots, and if those dots replicate great, then we have more belief. Science is about the evolution of knowledge, right? But the process is never ending. There will always be more things to uncover, more nuances. We get more certain about what it is we know, and we also get more certain about what are
所谓的边界条件或调节变量变得更加确定，例如，也许这种效应在城市地区成立，而在其他地方不成立。也许它在加利福尼亚成立，而在阿拉巴马州不成立。也许它对持有这些刻板印象的人成立，而对不持有的人不成立。对我和说，这是科学的进步。我们发现了所谓的主效应，即，你知道，刻板印象
called boundary conditions or moderators like, for example, maybe this effect holds in urban areas versus not. Maybe it holds in California and not in Alabama. Maybe it holds for people that are hold these stereotypes and maybe it doesn't hold for people that don't. That's, to me, that's an advance of science. We have found what's called a main effect, which is, you know, stereotypes
对结果有影响，或者启动效应对结果有影响，然后我们说，哦，顺便说一句，它在这些条件下不成立。这不是复现失败。这是对最初发现的更微妙的看法。在哈佛大学，丹·吉尔伯特说，你可以预期有些研究每次都能近乎完美地复现，但在其他情况下，你正在研究的事物本身正在发生变化。所以精确复现是不可能的。
have an effect on outcomes, or priming has an effect on outcomes, and then we say, oh, and by the way, it doesn't hold in these conditions. That's not a failure to replicate. That's a more nuanced view of the original finding. At Harvard, Dan Gilbert says you can expect some studies to replicate nearly perfectly every time, but in other cases, the very thing your studying is changing. So exact replications aren't possible.
心理学中有许多发现，我们预计几年后在不同的人群中能够相当精确地复现。眨眼条件反射就是一个很好的例子。如果我对着你的眼球吹气足够多次，当我抿起嘴唇时，你就会开始眨眼。在不同的文化、不同的时代、不同的年龄组中，这不会有太大差异。其他类型的发现当然会有所不同。社会心理学中我最喜欢的实验之一表明，当来自美国北部或南部的年轻男性
There are many findings in psychological science that we would expect to replicate quite exactly, years later and on different populations. I-blink conditioning is a very nice example. If I blow in your eye enough, you're going to start blinking as I purse my lips. And that's not going to be very different across cultures, across times, across age groups. Other kinds of findings certainly are. There's one of my favorite experiments in social psychology shows that when young men who are from the north or the south of the United States are
受到侮辱时，他们的反应截然不同，因为北方人和南方人有非常不同的荣誉准则。现在你不能把这个实验拿去，期望在意大利做，或者期望在25年后做。这是一个属于它自己的时刻和它自己的时代的实验。我交谈过的每一位研究人员都告诉我，科学界内部存在很多共识。当然有许多设计糟糕的科学研究。有些研究人员做粗制滥造的工作。大学和科学期刊面临着发表惊人发现的巨大压力。但所有这些问题的解决方案，埃里克·布拉德洛、布莱恩·诺塞克和丹·吉尔伯特说，是更多更好的科学。埃里克·布拉德洛。真相会大白。会有更多的点出现。
insulted, they react very differently because northerners and southerners have very different codes of honor. Now you can't take that experiment and expect to do it in Italy, we're expect to do it 25 years from now. It's an experiment that's of its moment and of its time. Every researcher I spoke with told me there's lots of agreement within the scientific community. There are certainly many scientific studies that are poorly designed. There are researchers who do shoddy work. There is great pressure at universities and scientific journals to publish striking findings. But the solution to all these problems, say Eric Bradlow, Brian, Nozek, and Dan Gilbert, is more and better science. Eric Bradlow. The truth will come out. More dots will come out.
如果事实证明我发表的内容，不是因为我做了什么欺诈行为，而只是由于样本量或我收集数据的方式而并非真实，那么你知道吗，科学最终会弄清楚我所说的是不真实的。所以如果你想要一个……布莱恩·诺塞克对他的关于可复现性的发现被理解为那些无法复现的研究毫无价值感到困惑。他启动了一个新系统，在这个系统中，研究人员为他们的研究注册方案并承诺
And if it turns out that what I published, it's not because I did anything fraudulent, just isn't true because of sample size the way I collected the data, then you know what, science will eventually figure out that what I'm saying is not true. So if you'd like a... Brian Nosek is bemused that his findings about replicability have been taken to mean that the studies that fail to reproduce are worthless. He started a new system where researchers register protocols for their studies and commit
坚持到底。科学期刊承诺发表这些研究的发现，无论结果是否具有吸引力。科学是积累证据的缓慢步伐，而且很容易想要一个简单的答案，就像真非假一样。但实际上，复现只是一种积累更多证据的机会，以便对该特定效应获得更精确的估计。对大多数人来说，关于科学真理的辩论是一个抽象的问题。我们大多数人向科学家寻求答案。我晚上应该喝一杯红酒吗？这种药给我生病的母亲吃安全吗？
to sticking to them. Scientific journals commit to publishing the findings of these studies, regardless of whether the results are sexy. Science is the slow march of accumulating evidence, and it's very easy to want a simple answer, as a true as a false. But really, replication is just an opportunity to accumulate more evidence to get a more precise estimate of that particular effect. To most people, the debate over scientific truth is an abstract issue. Most of us turn to scientists for answers. Should I drink a glass of red wine in the evening? Is this drug safe to give to my ailing mother?
我应该在每次我的孩子做了一件很酷的事情时给她一美元吗？实际上，科学更多的是处理问题的行业，而不是处理答案的行业。几乎每篇科学论文都以呼吁进行更多研究结束，这是有原因的。特别是在涉及人类行为时，几乎你可以对人类得出的每个结论都有大量的例外。人们是自私的吗？是的，除了每天有数百万人采取利他行为。
Should I give my kid a dollar every time she does something while it's cool? In reality, science is more in the question business than the answer business. There's a reason nearly every scientific paper ends with a call for more research. Especially when it comes to human behavior, nearly every conclusion you can draw about human beings has tons of exceptions. Are people selfish? Yeah, except millions act altruistically every day.
人类是善良的吗？是的，除了很少有物种能展现出更大的残忍。如果你想要永不改变的答案、决定性的结论和最终的真理，大概，你不需要去问科学家。《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉姆·阿加拉卡森、玛吉·佩恩曼和马克·内斯特拉克制作。你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台关注我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，考虑在iTunes上给我们写个评价。
Are humans kind? Yes, except that few species are capable of greater cruelty. If you want answers that never change, definitive conclusions and final truths, odds are, you don't want to ask a scientist. The Hidden Brain Podcast is produced by Karam Agarakaleson, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestrak. You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and follow my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, consider giving us a review on iTunes.
这将帮助其他人找到这个播客。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。感谢收听《隐藏的大脑》。如果你还没听过，请在手机上尝试NPR-1应用。你可以收听盖伊·拉兹对TED策展人克里斯·安德森的采访，他们讨论了公众演讲的艺术。你可以搜索节目，寻找当地电台的故事，并收听精彩的播客。NPR-1现在已经在应用商店上线。此外，《隐形》第二季将于6月17日回归。这一季，节目将前往监狱、石油钻井平台、
It will help other people find the podcast. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. Thanks for listening to Hidden Brain. If you haven't already, please try the NPR-1 app for your phone. You can hear Guy Razz's interview with Ted Curator Chris Anderson, where they discuss the art of public speaking. You can search for shows, find stories from your local station, and listen to great podcasts. NPR-1 is in the App Store now. Also, Invisibility Season 2 returns on June 17th. This season, the show goes to a prison, an oil rake,
俄罗斯的麦当劳和新泽西的一个海滩，探索工作、家庭和政府的世界。随时补看第一季，并在npr.org斜杠podcast以及NPR1应用上收听第二季的预告。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以留下评论。
a McDonald's in Russia, and a beach in New Jersey to explore the worlds of work, family, and government. Catch up on season one anytime and listen to the season two preview at npr.org slash podcast and on the NPR1 app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
俄罗斯的一家麦当劳，以及新泽西州的一处海滩，来探索工作、家庭和政府的世界。您可以随时收听第一季，并在 npr.org/podcast 以及 NPR1 应用上收听第二季的预告片。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。